good morning believe nation today's
message is being excited about your work
over to you Tom Ford I've always
believed that if you create something
that people want they buy it if they buy
it it causes sales if you have sales you
have money coming in it's quite simple
to me that but yes of course I'm
extremely aware of costs I'm very
cost-conscious i way you know is this
worth it is that worth it should we open
there should we not let's do the
performant as it work does it not work
there the part of selling is a you know
business is a part of designing a brand
you know it's yes it's maybe not the
visual part but you're building
something that's what I love about what
I do I get to design but I'm also
building I'm making not only a shoe a
beautiful dress and man suit I'm
building a company and that's exciting
it's exciting you have to be able to
motivate people you have to have a point
of view that you communicate to them and
you you build a company the way you
build a house and I find that incredibly
interesting so sales side is key it's
really part of building a brand building
a company building a solid business and
I find that fascinating and fun I think
most people aren't excited about that
work I think if you look at people
living in corporate America most people
are definitely not excited about their
work most people are driving to a job
that they hate and I living for the
evenings and the weekends and they're
stuck in traffic and just they're not
excited I think even though a lot of
entrepreneurs are not really excited
about their work and that's why so many
entrepreneurs fail most entrepreneurs
when they're getting started a lot of
them just see some opportunity I can
make a lot of money if I go and do this
and then they try and they usually lose
money they don't make anything off and
then we're back to that job that they
hate too and the key thing is you need
to have the past you need to have the
love because one it's the thing that
gets you through like if you don't if
you don't love your business
what you're doing you're gonna quit it's
just too hard there's too much crap that
gets thrown at you and for those of you
who are watching have a business right
now you know I'm talking about it's
insanely hard and you have to be doing
the thing that you would do even if you
weren't getting paid to do it
like you love with so much I would make
these videos even though wasn't getting
paid to do it because I love making them
I love doing the research for them I
love seeing your comments on them it
fuels me like it brings me life it fills
my soul that's what you need to do for
your business and it doesn't just infect
you it doesn't just give you the
motivation to keep going it infects
others it motivates other people it
motivates your team to come on board and
maybe the beginning volunteer time to
work with you it motivates suppliers
want to work with you and give you
better deals and motivates the media
right there motivates everybody around
you to want to help out and and it's
about setting higher standards for
yourself when you love what you're doing
you're gonna pour more energy into
making it great like you look at it and
say I know I can make that better or if
you just chase an opportunity like that
okay I hit that and life gets boring and
you'll physical up and want to go do
something else stop living in mediocrity
stop doing the nine-to-five stop trying
to chase an opportunity life is about
more than that trying to find the thing
that makes you come alive and if you
don't have it yet stop settling for
something that's okay go off and do
something that you can be great at that
fills you with joy that's what you want
to be doing for the rest of your life
so the question of the day today is are
you truly deeply excited about the work
that you're doing right now going deep
leave in the comments below I will join
the discussion thank you guys so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of interesting
- recipe Viggo